[Music]
hi everybody welcome back to Planet
coaster and I could say this again but
I've probably said this a bunch of times
already it's uh strange to say these
words again after so long anyway today
we're building Zephyr it's a muck
launched coaster or at least it's going
to be a machology in one second there we
go and it is my project mainly to mess
around with the mod tools now Planet
coaster has been modded for quite some
time there's the planco mod manager
which allows you to load a bunch of
different mods into the game and as some
of these have really changed the way
that you can build coasters now on
YouTube I've seen some great examples
from Miss ties and theme park World and
Other amazing creators with these tools
and the amount of things you can do with
it is absolutely ridiculous
nowadays people are able to make a
coasters much smoother than with the
in-game tools and even with the in-game
4 meter method if you could call that
in-game but you know you're already
stretching the coaster creation tools at
that point but today there are a couple
of parts of the mods that I want to
touch on the first is the ability to
make segments smaller than 4 meters
typically in the game you can only make
segments as small as 4 meters and the
idea of the 4 meter method is because of
the way that the camera moves around in
the game and because of the way that
there's no continuous role in the
banking system and the elements of the
game you'll always have some weird
jittery movements as you go from one
track piece to another and what the four
meter method does is it doesn't
eliminate these movements because it's
it's impossible to get rid of because
the game lacks continuous raw and the
camera of the game is a bit wonky like
that and the camera of the game is built
that way because the game doesn't have
continuous role to make The Coasters
feel a little bit smoother even though
you can never really get truly smooth
banking that Glides from one piece to
another and makes smooth transitions
anyway four meter method is kind of a
way to circumvent that a little bit and
at least try to approach the way that
coaster is in real life are designed and
the mods allow you to make 2 meter or
even 1 meter segments which still
doesn't make the coasters perfectly
smooth but it gets you closer to the way
that coasters look and feel in real life
and and if you put a lot of effort into
it you can make your coasters appear
much smoother this way and the two meter
method is something that I wanted to
experiment a little bit with and that's
why I started building this coaster
there wasn't really any idea behind this
no particular idea of how I wanted to
theme this or what kind of layout I
wanted to build or even if it was going
to end up as a video or not it's just
that after so long of playing Planet
coaster and not playing around with
these mod tools I finally wanted to try
my hand at them and um yeah this is my
attempt at doing so now at the same time
I wanted to come up with a fun layout
for this coaster so the idea for this is
I'm trying to combine some of my
favorite elements on real life coasters
and real-life coaster types into one big
layout that I would personally really
enjoy which is of course the fun of
playing games like these so we start off
with a launch because we all know that
launches are way cooler than lift Hills
and then after that we go into a top hat
but for the top hat I came up with a a
little bit of a ridiculous way that the
element uh goes about doing its top
heady things
um so we started off going up and then
we start twisting as we climb up the
hill into the other direction from where
the top hand is actually going and the
forces at that point are a little bit
wonky you get some weird lateral forces
and some air time at the top even that's
kind of sideways
um because I didn't want the raw to
happen too quickly you know this isn't a
super whole top head so we can't exactly
do that thing that Kingda car does where
it goes up and then it twists you about
and then it cleanly rolls you over the
top head again without twisting no you
have to start twisting and as we Crest
the the top of the top head we have to
twist back up to a regular position so
it's a bit of a strange element but I
think I really like it especially
because it's gonna give you that floaty
feeling the entire way through and I
find it very hard to think of exactly
how this would feel because I've never
been on an element that rides like this
and I don't think there's any Top Hand
in real life that does anything remotely
close to this but I I can imagine that
it's pretty fun you know as long as you
don't have very strong forces going into
any direction you can twist the track
about as much as you want and you'll
just have some lateral forces to deal
with from the twisting of the track but
that's not so bad so I think it's a it's
a pretty fun element after that we head
into ik4 getting it's horrible but no
it's an immelman that's kind of shaped
like the first element of formula and
um some of the many copies of formula
now formula is a vicoma new gen coaster
a coma New Gen Looper I guess I would
say it's in energy londia in Poland and
it just has this really strange first
element that kind of looks like a
regular imament but it just the loop
just keeps on going and then at the very
last moment it finally starts twisting
and you go back into an upright position
and it just gives you so much air time
especially because it's pretty slow
going through the loop that it feels
like a whole nother element even though
it's technically just a half Loop
followed by a dive Loop but uh yeah it's
really cool so I wanted to copy that and
after that we go into a little bit of uh
yeah what should we call this I'm not
I'm not entirely sure
it's inspired by intimate Mega lights so
we have two camelbacks just for some air
time very strong ejector airtime
throughout these entire camelbacks it's
a little bit like the layout of Rita or
speed at Heidi Park except the
camelbacks are way taller and have way
more air time but that's kind of the
idea putting two camelbacks on top of
each other
um it just feels pretty good
and then between the camelbacks we have
what's also a pretty typical element for
an intimate Mega light a very tight turn
with a lot of G's well upwards of 4GS
and very sustained so lots of negative
g-forces mixed with very dense positive
g-forces so it's it's gonna be pretty
extreme and then after that we have the
second inversion of the coaster which is
I'm not even entirely sure I guess it's
kind of like a corkscrew mixed with a
zero zero the thing is the way that it
enters the element is a little bit like
an elongated Corkscrew but after that it
just rolls straight into a turn in the
other direction so really not sure what
I would call this but yeah it goes into
a roll and that's the second and last
inversion of the layout and then the
final part of the layout is very much
like an intimate Mega light again where
you have two Twisted airtime Hills with
airtime that's not quite as intense as
the air time on the camelbacks but at
the same time it's a little bit twisty
so you you get yanked about from left to
right and yeah I think that's a good
finishing part of the coaster because at
this point I was trying to figure out
how I could make this thing return to
the station
um because I'd work myself into quite a
corner there and and eventually I
realized let's just build the station in
another Direction and then we'll have
plenty of space to work with to finish
the rest of the coaster so as you can
probably tell I'm a huge fan of intimate
Mega lights besides from just the
layouts being really fun and being one
of my favorite coaster layouts that I've
been on
I just appreciate how clever the design
of the layout is because intimate Mega
lights are a very small coaster at least
for the type of coaster that they are
because they have Giga coaster track and
cars that's usually reserved for
coasters well over 200 feet tall but
they're much smaller and yet they still
pack in all of those heavy positive G's
and lots of really intense air time and
the layout is just perfect you arrive at
the station thinking that you've just
had every little ounce of intensity that
you start off with or or like the
potential kinetic energy is completely
used and it's just perfect it's a
perfect little layout with just the
right mix of elements and Direction
changes so um yeah big fan so that's the
start of the layout
[Music]
now the next part that I had to do is
the two meter method and this is one
part where I ended up doing most of it
off camera because this is very boring
work as you can see it mostly entails me
having to remove all of the four meter
sections and replacing them with two two
meter sections and then smoothing it out
a bunch just to make sure it doesn't
look too wonky so this means doubling
the amount of track pieces uh going
through the entire Track by hand and
removing and replacing all of these
segments and finally and thankfully this
is something where the mod tools can
help you can see the tools to smooth
forward is smooth backward and burst
smooth basically what you want to do is
to go back and forth with the old 4
meter method technique to smooth the
whole coaster is you want to select some
segments and then smooth them all
backwards and forwards and at least with
the mod tools you can do this very
quickly and easily with the smooth
forward and backward buttons so that
helps but still this was a a process
that takes hours and was kind of painful
but the result is nice
[Music]
by the way before I forget huge credit
goes to Evan and distance who created
the PC mod manager and also the realism
mod that allows you to do all kinds of
things with the game I'll leave a link
to the Discord in the description so you
can check it out for yourself do be
warned it's quite a process to figure
out how these mods work exactly and how
to install them but once you get used to
it it's really fun and messing around
with them is really cool there are all
kinds of mods available also to change
the look of cars in the game there are
many reshade presets and stuff
especially those shared by missed eyes
are really amazing so it's a great tool
to figure out what else you can do with
the game anyway the next part of this
video is all about supports and
something I noticed that I'm just gonna
say outright is that I forgot to put
flanges on the support while I was
recording so I did what YouTubers do
best and I did some more off-camera work
all things considered if I took all of
the footage that I recorded for this
coaster with the smoothing process and
the supports and stuff like that and
actually included all of that I could
make a bunch of videos on it but it
would get very boring so I decided that
I would just make this into one huge
video but do let me know if you guys
prefer having some smaller bite-sized
videos released over a couple of weeks
of me working on this because truth be
told I've been working on this coaster
for the past couple months it sounds
very dramatic it doesn't take that much
effort
um but I just haven't had that much free
time so it's uh it's it's been a long
labor of love I should say anyway the
support structure is inspired by muck
coasters and to be very honest I'm not
very used to building Mac coasters one
thing that helped with this is that
there is a theme makers toolkit mug
track connector available because it
does look a little bit different from
the intimate connectors but because muck
typically uses these triangular Flats
track connectors that connect the track
to the support and intimate uses these
thick tubes that go into the track
itself so if you want to make your
coasters realistic for the real roller
coaster nerds out there these are the
kind of things you have to try to pay
attention to and when it comes to
support structures you can also tell
some of the differences between
manufacturers and this actually kind of
fun to talk about honestly
especially gerstlauer has a very
recognizable style of supports which is
that they over support many of their
coasters they typically have huge
structures with lots of cross beams and
they just look super complicated and in
comparison Mark I think has some of the
simpler more vertical support structure
so these as well you can see are quite
slender quite vertical not so many cross
beams and complicated supports but there
are lots of supports and you might find
a few somewhat fewer connectors in gurus
Lauer's case for instance so all these
things are the the touches that really
make a coaster recognizable for the
company that built it to be very honest
though I don't think this layout is very
typical of Mach I think my head Cannon
for this coaster is that I was a park
owner and I wanted to build this coaster
and I just went up to Mark and I was
like
I want this coaster that takes these
elements from the intimate megalite
coasters and takes these elements from
the new generation the coma coasters but
I want to use your track and your cars
and then somehow come to some kind of uh
yeah combination of all of these parts
which is more common than you'd think
there's an interesting muck coaster
called Alpena Blitz which is technically
brilliant intimate megalite the layout
is almost an exact clone of the intimate
Mega light layout except it's built by
Mark and it's because the port the the
park niglo land supposedly went up to
muck and they were like we want this
coaster that intimate delivers but we
want your trains and everything so they
ended up going with muck instead which I
can also kind of see why the Muk trains
that they're using and it's the same
train type that's in Planet coaster and
then I'm using for this coaster
it's just really comfortable and as much
as I like the intimate Mega light
coasters that were huge Inspirations for
this layout the intimate Mega lights
still use the old intimate Trains And
while I think they're very comfortable
they're very low to the ground and they
have stadium seating and just a lap bar
to hold you in so you can really feel
the airtime very well they're not quite
as cushioned and comfortable as some of
the newer intimate or muxtile coaster
trains so that's somewhat understandable
Plus in Planet coaster I ended up going
for this coaster type 2 because it just
felt right considering that this layout
is clearly quite new it has elements
that really wouldn't have been done in
the times of the uh intimate megalite so
I think it makes sense to go with newer
trains and if we have to go with newer
trains I think the Mach trains in the
game are just really good
but honestly if we had new generation
vicoma tracks and coaster trains I might
have gone for those as well but alas
that's not how the world works
that said those things are amazing for
anybody who doesn't know what I'm
talking about when I'm talking about New
Generation vicomas the coma is a company
that's typically used known for just
horrible coasters and for many decades
now has been mostly known for their
boomerangs and suspended looping
coasters which bang you about which are
usually pretty painful so their
reputation wasn't really too good but
since about 2015 and very slowly
starting from that point they've had a
new track type new coaster trains and
their stuff is really smooth and they're
kind of going through a Renaissance and
I find that more and more coaster
enthusiasts these days are rating them
very highly sometimes maybe even
overrating them but that's getting into
very controversial territory but yeah
for coma coasters are nowadays some of
the smoothest in the market
there's no denying that sometimes
personally I feel that they are a little
bit too smooth in a sense that their
layouts tend to be so perfectly
calculated in a computer that they don't
really whip you around as much and I do
like the kind of unwieldy air time and
Direction changes that you get on older
Intimates like the intimate Mega lights
but yeah they're super smooth coasters
they're really fun they also use very
unique elements they're always coming up
with new elements that we haven't seen
before so all things considered great
coaster type and would love to see them
in Planet coaster personally I've been
on formula in energy londia in Poland
and on Lech coaster which is in legendia
also in Poland and these were some of
the First new generation for coma
coasters I think that really showed the
coaster Enthusiast Community just how
much vicoma has changed I've heard
recently that Lech coaster has been
getting a little bit rough when I wrote
it which was a couple of years ago it
was super smooth and super intense and
it had crazy airtime and positive
g-forces
but perhaps the park isn't maintaining
the thing too well so that's a bit of a
shame but aside from that all of the new
Jennifer Comas are buttery smooth same
goes for abysses which is a newer new
genva coma that I haven't been on yet
which is also in energy londia and then
there's also phonics which is a nugen
which is in Far rip Summerland which I
have written last summer and which is
also fantastic not quite as intense as
lack coaster but it still has those
really unique elements and the super
smooth ride experience that we've gotten
used to from for coma in the last couple
of years but back to the game by the way
there's something that you might have
noticed that's a little bit particular
about the way that I'm building these
supports so as you can see I'm
continuing in the trend of very
simplistic supports mostly vertical very
steep angles
but I'm not actually using support
pieces for this even though the game has
support pieces and there are even some
theme makers toolkit support beams I
decided to still go with the basic
shapes to make these supports which kind
of comes down to a preference of texture
I compared the basic shapes to the
support beams and the support beams are
a little bit they have a little bit more
wear on them it seems they're a little
bit more grimy reflect light a little
bit more and these beams are just more
saturated somehow the texture is just a
little bit different a little bit less
visible even and because this coaster at
least in my head Cannon is a very new
coaster I wanted the support beams to
also look very new and freshly painted
so that's why I ended up still going for
the basic pieces unfortunately this
means that these supports have way too
many pieces the piece count in this is
way too high for pretty simple supports
so I've already thrown my chances of
making is a blue printable build out the
window with that I'm sorry about that
you guys I would have liked to make this
an easy plop and go blueprint but
unfortunately I already went overboard
with the supports and once you guys see
the roof of the station you're gonna
figure that the chances of making this a
blueprint are going to be even Slimmer
but you'll see about that in a couple
minutes or even less than a couple
minutes it's coming up very soon I see
because yeah the supports are almost
finished just the last bit of track here
to be done and some photos to put in
place and then we're almost there and as
you can see I forgot about the flanges
never ever forget to place the flanges
on your supports you have to always make
sure you place them in logical positions
so that at least the supports look like
they could be taken apart and there we
go that's the flanging process and
um yeah you could load them onto a truck
and stuff like that now I wanted to say
that beforehand because I could already
see some comments coming but as you can
see we still have to do our due
diligence and actually Place some
flanges here and there
um personally I always just eyeball this
it's just about the length that a
support beam I think could be to fit on
the truck and to also have logical
pieces so typically you want your
connecting pieces and your more
complicated pieces to be a single piece
as well and you can have very long
straight sections of supports between
that too it's a small touch but if
they're missing it's just something that
once you notice it you can't unnotice it
anymore and the whole coaster looks
unrealistic so small things but
definitely important to add to your
courses as well but that's all for the
supports so let's start building a
station
foreign
so for the station I didn't really have
any particular theme or idea in mind I
just knew that I wanted to try something
different and something kind of
unexpected I think it was very easy for
this station to just go with some
generic roller coaster station with
metal plated roofs and support beams and
stuff like that and just throw some of
the colors of the coaster in there but I
wanted to try something else and what I
wanted to try I wasn't really sure
either I decided to just treat this as a
doodle and see wherever it ends up which
is really fun to do I think all of the
time sometimes it ends up horribly wrong
when you end up with a building that you
don't like but most of the time you at
least end up with something interesting
that kind of starts as something unusual
or something you haven't tried before
and ends up as something presentable at
least it's just a it's mostly a fun
process honestly to not know exactly
what your building is going to look like
and just start building it and hope for
the best now I did have some very
general inspiration for this build
although that's also
coming from a slightly different place
than you'd usually think of when it
comes to roller coaster stations see I
was thinking of architecture from the
post-war period in the Netherlands so
something like the 40s and 50s where
there was a lot of well we had to
rebuild the country from the rebels of
World War II and there was a lot of
experimental concrete modernist
architecture and it's something that
inspired me most of all is the
architecture from blidorp which is the
zoo in Rotterdam designed by SeaWorld
from ravenstein which is technically
built during the war period and designed
before it but um that doesn't matter too
much it's just a general architecture
and also the architecture of modernist
churches which sounds especially strange
but I figured it's a it's a cool look
and I wanted to experiment with it a
little bit so starting off we have this
big concrete roof with with its kind of
unusual shape
some people told me that it looks a
little bit like an Asian roof which was
not my intention but I see the
resemblance so fair enough honestly and
I think it kind of Suits the tropical
Vibe of this whole build so I'm not even
mad but the general idea of this roof
was just to build something with a more
unusual shape than a typical coaster
station roof and then figure out what to
do with the rest of the building later
so as for the rest of the building I
decided to put these white simple
pillars underneath it which which really
makes it resemble a building from
bladorp those of you who know you'll
know what I mean and as a foundation
we're just going for a very simple base
with some natural rock textures and
stuff like that it's a very rectangular
building which is kind of against my uh
principles honestly making a building
that's perfectly rectangular or Square
is just horrible not a big fan of it but
in this case it just works the best with
the roof structure and we'll add an
extra element to this building later on
that'll make it a bit more interesting
Than This plus there's the fact that the
station is raised quite tall so we're
gonna have to play some stuff around
this to not make this whole building
feel a little bit alienated in its
environment but that's all going to be
fine for now I'm just working on some of
the finishing touches making sure the
whole thing looks clean because if
you're building a building like this in
a kind of modernist sense I think the
most important thing is to make it look
clean and make everything very tidy and
connect well I think one of the biggest
gripes that people have with modernist
architecture from this era so modernist
architecture that's over 50 years old
but it's still very typically modernist
architecture is that concrete just
starts looking not as good as it was
when it was newly built you know it
starts weathering and typically when
you're building brick buildings or other
vernacular architecture weathering is
kind of a good thing you know a brick
building that that's very old you really
start seeing the age in the bricks and
they start uh getting some darker colors
and some more variety in the texture and
it looks cool but with concrete
buildings concrete just doesn't age too
well and instead it starts looking a
little bit dirty and grimy and dark
um so I think that's a huge part of why
these kinds of concrete buildings aren't
too popular especially if they're older
but in this case this is very new
building it's a new station and
um we're gonna do something with this
roof to make it look more interesting
than just its boring uncolored shape so
my idea was uh to just paint it in in a
weird sense I was thinking of what I
could do with the colors for a while
maybe some sort of checkerboard pattern
or something like that many different
colors but eventually I ended up with
this a little bit strange-ish shape
which I think kind of Suits the way that
this roof is built because you do have
two diagonal lines going down the middle
to the middle of the roof just by the
the way that the the curved shape is
made
and I think making a pattern like this
where it's a little bit darker towards
the middle of these lines and then
getting lighter towards the end
um at least gives it an interesting look
that's better than the the gray concrete
that it was before so that's how we
started out with the station building
but then I wanted to create a Finishing
Touch to support the roof line and
decided to add a big arch at the end and
the exit or uh yeah at both sides of the
station building
um to make it look a bit more
interesting so that's that for now
thank you
so after I finished the station building
off camera it is what it is I'm still a
YouTuber after all and also these time
lapses segments are actually not all in
chronological order so if you're paying
attention very well you might notice
some continuity errors here and there
but
it is what it is I decided to divide
this video into different thematic
sections I just wasn't as thorough when
I was actually building this coaster
anyway this section is about path works
but also a little bit more than that
it's really just the whole environment
of the coaster and everything around it
and basically the context that makes it
feel like this could be a coaster in a
real theme park and not just something
in a grassy sandbox now I wanted to try
something with kind of free-flowing
paths here with large sections of uh
yeah what should we call them sort of
Planters with mulch in them that nearly
freshly planted bushes and stuff would
be in and because of that and because
this is such a new coaster the terrain
is mostly going to be devoid of large
trees because large trees just haven't
had time to grow in yet and instead we
have these Mochi Fields with very small
shrubs and Ferns and palm trees that
still need to grow in between a couple
of large palm trees that we did manage
to get the budget for to bring over to
the section of the park and actually
plants in place and that's honestly
something that when it comes to the lore
of building a new attraction in a team
Park you always have to keep these
things in mind Landscaping is something
that takes years to fully grow and
really make a place look finished so
most new areas of a theme park I think
even though they end up looking very new
and clean are not the nicest looking
areas of a park personally I think
anyway because the foliage all still
needs Room to Grow I think you see this
especially right now in Dollywood with
Big Bear Mountain which is a really cool
coaster it's a new Jennifer coma
actually and it's a family coaster with
three launches and really cool layout it
looks amazing I would love to ride it
honestly if I would ever stayed side but
it's also nicknamed Big Bear Mountain
after the animal but um some people also
call it Big Bear mountain with b-a-r-e
because it's just it's such a Barren
landscape but it's part of building a
new coaster and demolishing all of the
trees that were in its place you can
build coasters around trees and maybe
even do path works and buildings around
them and keep most of the trees intact
you can see this especially with parks
that have environmental restrictions
where they're in some sort of nature
reserve area so they're not allowed to
demolish trees I think Daniel in the
Netherlands is an interesting example of
this where one of The Coasters dragonfly
was really built around the trees in the
area and they didn't chop down any or at
the very least many trees to construct
the coaster but yeah aside from those
kind of exceptions new areas of parks
tend to look up tend to look quite bare
so that's something to keep in mind when
you're doing these Planet coaster builds
as well that if you want your Coast to
look new you should also keep the
foliage quite small and that's what I'm
gonna be doing in this case
and I'm doing a brief intermittent over
here to build some catwalks some custom
catwalks for no other reason than the
fact that apple looks at the planet
coaster catwalks for way too many times
and there's just something fun about
taking some other catwalks every now and
then and using those instead
and here you can see I filled in this
soily area with all kinds of small
foliage
some of these are in game but most of
these are not from the game and are
either small the makers toolkit plants
or actually planters that I sunk into
the ground to just use the small Bush on
top but in any case it looks kind of new
also the general look of this area was
inspired by pipeline the surf coaster
which is a new b m coaster that opened
in SeaWorld Orlando this year which is a
really cool looking coaster it's a new
type of stand-up coaster developed by b
m where the seats move up and down with
the forces so hopefully and from what
I've heard from reviews it's actually
pretty good hopefully it should resolve
the issue where the forces are very
uncomfortable on traditional stand-up
coasters stand-up coasters used to be
kind of a hype in the coastal world in
the late 80s early 90s but have mostly
disappeared and many have been
demolished in the last couple of years
because they're they just don't have a
really great reputation but the surf
coaster looks to be a cool Innovation
that makes these things good again so um
maybe I'll write that poster one day too
but uh if you've ever been on it do let
me know if it's a if it's a good ride
but it seems to be getting really good
uh reviews but I'm not even thinking
about the coaster itself I'm actually
thinking about the landscaping around it
I've heard many people call it also kind
of barren and ugly but personally I kind
of like the clean landscaping around the
coaster with all of the curvy concrete
curbs and the different sections of path
and Sandy bits and stuff like that so I
was mostly inspired by the way that
coaster looks to make the surroundings
of this coaster
and so instead of just having it go over
grassy fields and maybe adding some
bushes or Rock work here and there I
decided to make it a bit more fancy and
also landscape
some of the areas around the coaster a
bit more so the concrete walls and curbs
make their return here around the
coaster almost as if it was some kind of
path but it's not where this is also a
pretty time consuming process so I did
cut out some of this as well
um but yeah all things considered I
think it's worth doing it and especially
from an aerial perspective it really
makes the coaster look clean and kind of
new and I think it's a it's a fun way to
at least make this super unthemed
coaster at least have something to look
at and I think it suits the colorful and
tropical Vibe of the coaster as well so
that's what we're going for
and of course you should try to build
these things in a smart efficient kind
of way as well so once you've built one
of these curves definitely just copy
them around and which also helps you to
make sure that all of the curves are
similar and have the same radius and
then try to figure out how you can
actually make them connect as you can
see here it's not always super easy but
the end result is something that looks
pretty clean I think and gives you
something fun to fill in and give this
coaster a unique look even though it is
still completely un themed
um and it's just fun to see how quickly
you can make these things look decent
just by copying all of these
semi-circles around you can also
probably see me getting a little bit
faster at this once I get used to how
they look and their shape and size Works
to make this whole area now finally I
wanted to fill in some of these other
curves with sand still not entirely sure
what I was thinking when I did this but
honestly I was just copying the general
look of pipeline the surf coaster
and it's again something that's a little
bit time consuming also this sand is
just the mulch a piece that I used for
the soily bits except I recolored it to
look like this so
these kinds of recolorable pieces are
very flexible when it comes to this
stuff but yeah in the end I think it
just provides a really fun color
contrast with the grass and the mulch to
just make the ground look a bit more
interesting
plus filling these in is kind of
satisfying I think it's just the kind of
task where you can turn your brain off
and just do Mindless little tasks like
this and watch something just get nicer
and I think that's the fun therapeutic
part of doing stuff like this so
I think it looks worse to do than it
really is it's just kind of fun with
some good music or stuff like that it's
it's something I could easily do for
days also the fun fact some of the
building of this coaster actually
streamed on Twitch now I'm not going to
promise that I'll be streaming regularly
because honestly I just stream whenever
I feel like it but the streams were
really fun to do so huge thanks to
everyone who joined in and watched me
finish this coaster because it was a lot
of fun and sometimes it's also these
kind of things that keep you going
because I know it's sometimes difficult
to find the motivation to actually
finish your projects in the game if you
will and doing stuff like that and
making these videos really motivates me
also to finish these builds because for
some reason the last few steps are
always the hardest I always begin with a
lot of motivation
and then once the steps to finish it are
clear
it just becomes a little bit more boring
but uh it is what it is it's still a
game and you should still just do it for
fun and now after I finish this corner
here you can kind of get a quick aerial
Glimpse at what the coaster looks like
with all of path work around it I'm
going to keep the part work over here a
little bit more simple and I also wanted
to create a lake on this side because
that is going to be my money shot
whenever I do Planet coaster builds I
always try to come up with a couple of
camera angles where a coaster is going
to look nicest and some of these you
really want some parts and some of these
I just want a space where I can where I
know I'll be able to make some cinematic
shots and make something that looks good
and maybe even make it my thumbnail for
the video so these are always things
that I keep in mind as well
and now here these paths look kind of
boring even though their surroundings
are pretty clean I think so I wanted to
make some planters to put some big palm
trees in and really make it give it that
tropical look and also some very simple
Street furniture and just some simple
lights I believe these are still from
the Ghostbusters DLC they're the the old
city lights but they work pretty nice
for stuff like this
and some fences here and there as well
of course
and the queue line is also pretty simple
as you can tell just a very simple
Switchback
where we will place some some shade
covers very soon
um but nothing too special honestly
um because I'm keeping this very simple
trying to keep it within one video and
not put too much work on it plus the
focus is still on the coaster mainly
also all of these paths were actually
pathless up until very recently but I
did all of this forgetting that the
guests in Planet coaster are kind of
boring and don't even walk anywhere if
they don't have anything to do there so
even though they can get some great
views of the coaster nobody's actually
gonna walk on any of these paths so I
kind of uh forgot that's how Planet
coaster guests work but you'll have to
forgive me it's been a while
anyway here's where I'm gonna Place some
of the shade covers over the queue line
this could have been more shady I
definitely see that but honestly it just
looks better this way I think
um plus there are some queue lines in
this world in warm and sunny places that
are uh barely shaded at all which I find
really confusing as much as the look of
an area is important
um having enough shade is crucial and
you know looking at this build in
general I think I don't even have enough
shade in this build especially some of
the large path works are going to be
very warm on sunny days so apologies for
that I really shouldn't have said
anything about this kind of stuff
because maybe you guys wouldn't have
noticed and just thought it looked good
um but yeah you need more shade in areas
like these than I've placed here it's a
it's a little bit iffy but uh unless it
is what it is also the station itself is
at least very shaded and you definitely
need some shade for The Operators of any
and all attractions in your theme park
at least I am adding some more Greenery
I think in terms of adapting to rainfall
and making this area green enough I
don't think it's too bad so gonna put in
some extra Planters with these custom
made brick walls I'm still such a fan of
these brick items ever since I
discovered how useful they are in
aerobats in of Arabia in making some
brick walls that are highly detailed and
textured
um I've just been addicted to them maybe
it is gonna add to the piece count of
this build a little too much but you
know with that roof of the station and
the supports for The Coasters or
supports for the coaster it's gonna have
way too many pieces anyway so whatever
and finally with some simple Footers and
some lights for these Shade Sails the
queue line is more or less finished I'm
Gonna Keep the in-game fences around
even though they're not the best looking
because I think they do the the job fine
enough that I think it's gonna be so
much effort for so little game to
replace these fences especially on the
curved bits uh and it's just gonna not
look as clean as the in-game fences are
I think it's fine to go with in-game
items every now and then if it's uh the
best looking and easiest option the only
reason I tend to avoid using in-game
pieces too much is because you've seen
them all so many times so you know some
change is nice every now and then
finally I wanted to finish this area
with a bunch of foliage and as you can
see I'm just going for a very simple
three line by sinking a bunch of trees
in the ground and adding trees on top of
that later
it's not the best looking kind of
foliage but it's the kind of quick and
dirty that I think is fine for something
like this
um especially because you know if I
wouldn't say this and if this weren't a
time lapse you probably wouldn't have
noticed how janky it actually is but
with realistic foliage you just see
through it too much and it would be too
obvious that we're on an empty sandbox
otherwise even if you're looking at the
coaster from a grand perspective so yeah
that is going to be the Finishing Touch
for this build I'm gonna add some last
couple of things here and there to
really finish it up but
for now that's gonna be it for the time
lapse I hope you guys enjoyed this look
into the process of making this coaster
and I'll leave you guys with a few
cinematic shots and a POV
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]